au
gibier mais j'ai de caméra cachée
non au massacre des sapins à noël non au
massacre des sapins de noël non salée
pour les ponts
c'est
vraiment vite et sur mon trottoir là
parce que vous vendez des sympas où vous
vendez
c'est moi de vous emmerder les airs en
mer des eaux si oui alors j'appelle les
freak pourquoi c'est pas une solution
si tu l'as pas fait chier des bras mais
je fais pas chier merci mais non merci
non allez vous voulez vous la mettez du
rouge du bleu la ville étouffe ici
j'arrive même pas inspiré c'est
peut-être ça s'arrête là il est mort
alors tout
ça n'est pas ça sa photo foot renseigner
parce que là franchement pour moi tu es
ridicule c'est bien le geste non mais là
mais là je dire si c'est quoi ces
lunettes c'est les red sox était
ridicule c'est la démarche quelque part
les ridicules parce que nous sachant que
la démarche comme ça tu veux ça ridicule
ce que vous faite puisque la fait pas
c'est pas saccager la nature du fait
qu'ils sont poussés pour ce n'est pas ça
que j'ai commencé
ils sont cultivés et 3 pour être coupée
par la suite ce n'est pas du chantage on
ne sait pas d'où ça vient c'est bien
imiter quand même voilà le pauvre
regardez-moi ça les peintres
les bailleurs non
rien dorion on a chanté plus de sa part
ni un blanc dit un verre le seul vivre
cette conifères non roma serait plus
sympa noz arrêtez arrêtez pas ça mais
non mais vous êtes fous laissez-le ces
lieux se trouve dans la
salle est déjà vu la maman d'un sapin en
train de voir son petit se faire couper
la queue comme ça vous pourrez vous ça
vous plaît
mais c'est pas une raison
regardez c'est un truc suffit maintenant
non on s'appelle moi
alors je peux pas ce papa non non je
peux pas je peux pas il ya trop de vent
je peux rester là non c'est mieux moi ça
ne fait pas de publicité aussi pour mais
sa fin mais c'est fait pour
nous sommes non
non non
maintenant non au massacre des manteaux
de fourrure non au massacre des manteaux
de fourrure non au massacre des sapins
de noël non on massacre des manteaux de
fourrure non au massacre des sapins
sonné fun de rené de chaîner non aux
massages
[Musique]